it's it's interesting right like Jorge  came out against him like just a lot of  Fighters talk [ __ ] about DC  and I think it's a case of you know DC's  top of the food chain Right light  heavyweight champ heavyweight champ  um if he's a smaller weight I don't  think they would do it but because he's  bigger they know the bigger guy's not  gonna do anything to them so they're  gonna fire shots at him name one person  who's currently fighting that's taught  or hasn't that stocks [ __ ] about DC that  could beat him up I'd love to hear it  not one of them  but I'm telling you man anybody who's  taking shots at DC keep that same energy  if DC was being serious you guys would  get [ __ ] up but you know he's not  gonna do anything because he's a  professional and he works for the UFC  commentating team but if he wasn't